Guten Morgen Linus.
Es ist dem Feind gelungen den Proteste breiter Formation zu durchbrechen,
priluka der Gegner Artikel 11 genommen und stößt mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht vor der Feind operiert jetzt an rechtlichen Rand zwischen Brüssel und Straßburg und dem Rad mit der Feind bis zu Artikel 13 gelangt.
Mit der Online-Petition wird das alles in Ordnung kommen.
YouTube konnte nicht genügend Bots für eine Ablehnung massieren die Ablehnung ist nicht erfolgt.
Bleiben im Raum Edinger Märkte und Bali.
Das war ein Befehl die Ablehnung von Artikel 13 war dafür sind sie dass sie es wagen sich meinen Befehlen zu widersetzen.
Jonas mich verloren die gesamte ist nichts weiter niederträchtiger.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 287 aufgenommen am 21 Februar 2019 in der Metaebene.
Und wir sollen Tribut an einen großartigen Künstler der uns auf eine gewisse Art.
Groß Hattingen YouTube.
Bruno Ganz der Sach lange erhalten bleiben wird oder vielleicht auch nicht wer weiß.
Wie heißt NH.
Obst mit dem eben nicht.
Stimmt die.
Schon wieder vorbei.
Die Untergang meme waren ja schon vor Jahren immer großes T.
Constantin Film war da immer hinterher und hat immer ordentlich hinterher gearbeitet was jetzt mittlerweile aufgegeben haben oder ob das immer noch so ein,
so ein hinrennen ist wo es immer wieder hin und her geht das auf jeden Fall wird sagen für Deutschland das beste Beispiel.
Hatte also eine Katastrophe na eine der berühmtesten Filmszenen überhaupt ne imitiert persifliert.
Eines deutschen eines deutschen Films.
Genau.
Die alte Hütte getippt die ein deutschsprachiger Film irgendwie mal mittelfristig gelandet hat ja oder so ausmachen.
Ja ich weiß natürlich muss man sagen auch immer so ein bisschen in Zugzwang auch durch die Regularien die sich selber eingetreten haben durch ihren Lobbyismus
weil wenn du dann dein Urheberrecht nicht,
Volks dann für wirkst du es vielleicht etcetera also bist du auch ein bisschen gefangen auf wenn ich ehrlich gesagt nicht sehe dass wir dies und einer etwas nachlässiger damit umgeht gleich alles verloren ist von da ist das wahrscheinlich auch um.
In diesem Punkt ganz interessant ich hatte ja glaube ich in der letzten Sendung erwähnt dass sich dass diese Aufzeichnung der Sendung timster des Kika Kinderkanal,
veröffentlicht habe ha.
War gleich wieder weg.
Copyright claim von ARD was ich auch richtig krass finde ne also diese ich bin ja ein großer Freund des Gebühren finanzierten
Rundfunk weil ich das wichtig finde dass das da eben auch ja fernab von kommerziellen Zwängen unbedingt dir Zone
bikehit Programm geliefert werden kann jetzt komplett Musikantenstadl ist kein Feld ja stimmt das heißt aber nicht nur weil es auch Quatsch oder schlechte Programme gibt oder weil die auch mein Fehler machen das man direkt das ganze Bad mit dem Kind aus Gießen muss aber,
so dass wir das REWE diese Inhalte öffentlich finanzieren,
und dann werden sie die publiziert was bei kika passieren wird irgendwie in zwei Wochen ist das video für immer verschwunden,
weil sie das geht alle weil sie wieder diesen was ist das.
Der kann auf der Axel-Springer-Verlag kein Geld mehr verdienen wenn das im Internet.
Hör diese die Publikation Pflicht kommt aber von dem Rundfunk medienstaatsvertrag da habe.
Ja gut aber die Siri.
Den Jahren irgendwie drüber geschrieben auf netzwelt.de Korg aber.
Aber es kommt wegen dieses Lobbyismus mit dieser Argumentation.
Kommt auf das waren da da schon die Feinde sind auch in dieser Sendung wieder Ja und,
dass sie dann sogar noch hinterher gehen ja wenn ich es könnte dieses dieses Video das gibt es bis die publikations Zwanges,
NTBA und auf YouTube rette,
oder geht sie dann noch hinterher und Lebens runter jetzt muss ich das noch mal bei mir selber also hatte ich eh schon welcher wusste die neben das runter bei mir selber auf der auf der Homepage noch mal veröffentlicht dir aktuell noch ohne,
Upload Filter funktioniert konnte ich hochladen gegen.
Okay auf den eigenen Server wow.
Auf mein eigenes Server ging.
Weißes diese Sendung für die Kinder von morgen wenn Sie das in 500 Jahren nach klingt wie Science-Fiction aus der Vergangenheit.
Vor allem klingt die sendung wie Logbuch Netzpolitik in 10 Jahren weil ich meine Stimme ein bisschen gelitten hat wenn ich ehrlich sein soll also ich bin nicht krank bin auch nicht gealtert aber.
Untergang bist du nah.
Es war halt ein Befehl,
servus einfach mal gesagt werden dass wir mal wohl noch sagen dürfen.
Genau für Leute die irgendwie immer noch nicht wissen worauf er eigentlich anspielen das kann ja auch sein also man kann das jetzt nicht ausschließen vielleicht noch mal kurz der Hinweis also man sollte in seinem Leben,
den Film der Untergang gesehen haben und zwar nicht nur diese eine Szene sondern den ganzen film weil es nicht wirklich war ein ganz groß.
Austragen des Erg.
Herausragendes Werk der auf die beeindruckende Art und Weise vielleicht den wichtigsten geschichtlichen Moment Deutschland dokumentiert,
und ja Bruno Ganz Performance findet sich immer wieder hervor gestellten man kann halt im Prinzip auch sagen auch all die Leute die an diesem Drehbuch geschrieben haben und diese,
diese Szene gestaltet haben bist schon.
Burgund und ich finde immer wieder lustig nicht nur wenn es jetzt im Internet mimetisch aufgenommen wird sein ja auch in anderen Film,
ja wo ich mich halt auch Frage wenn die dann auch eigentlich vom Netz genommen ja also ist ja sozusagen nicht nur,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass dafür eine Lizenz,
Zahlung erfolgt oder irgendeiner Form einer Nutzung gemacht es gibt zwei schöne Beispiele wo das aufgegriffen wird es sind beides jetzt auch Filme die expliziten Hitler Bezug haben was vielleicht viele auch kennen
iron Sky hat mit so einem Sarah Palin Verschnitt in einer Sehne das aufgegriffen das Kino Gesicht nachdem ich auch komplett ins Essen gefallen,
und erst gestern hatte ich die Gelegenheit mir mal den Film er ist wieder da anzuschauen hinduja glaube ich noch nicht kennst ne.
Ich habe aber gerade diesen Ausschnitt eigentlich.
Es ist also ganz ehrlich hört euch den mal an,
obwohl sundridge Beispiel für bist bin er ja sehr kritische aber,
das hat mir wirklich sehr gut gefallen die Idee eines wieder
durch irgendeine ominöse Zeitreise in die aktuelle Gegenwart transportierten Adolf Hitler der dann einfach sofort wieder sein Programm aufnimmt und dabei einfach auch genau,
das von 2013 oder 14 genau das aufnimmt was wir jetzt auch gerade erleben so dieses
Provokation ist Entertainment das Privatfernsehen nimmt das dann auf weil es verkauft sich ja so gut ach und man muss das ja alles nicht so genau nehmen und das ist ja eigentlich nur Spaß und,
in gewisser Hinsicht hat der Film bis dann,
doch sehr schön gespielt und auch dort gibt es das Aufgreifen dieses Untergang nehmen.
Übrigens Logbuch Netzpolitik folge 4 vom 22 November 2011,
behandelt diese gesamte Constantin Film YouTube Geschichte in irgendeiner Form
mit ich sehe das gerade nur dass nur noch mal gegoogelt und ich glaube wir haben,
da auch schon irgendwie mal uns an einer an einem teilzitat,
Gemüse nicht in mir kam es gerade ich hatte gerade so ein Deja Vu.
Nicht dass wir uns wieder an alles erinnern würden was wir hier schon mal gemacht haben.
Merken was kümmert mich mein Geschwätz von gestern ja.
Ja Turboboost hieß die Sendung und war nur 40 Minuten.
Da passt du das noch.
Und das ist auf wow.
Ja aber.
7 Jahre her.
Genau sieben Jahre ist das her und wir müssen heute weitermachen.
Mit Feedback und zwar Verständnisfrage oder nicht unverständlich ich sage jetzt mal verständnisvoll von Peter,
Peter per E-Mail schrieb was ich jetzt nicht verstehe es wer sagt denn dass es eine Schwachstelle die jetzt jemand kauft noch gibt wenn man sie in vielleicht zehn Jahren mal bräuchte.
Es gibt ja immer die Möglichkeit dass eine Schwachstelle in der Zwischenzeit gefunden wurde dem Hersteller gemeldet wurde und beseitigt wurde Frage zu der Idee dass man überhaupt Schwachstellen kauft ja,
Thema Cyberwar und so weiter staatliche Stellen wollen das Wissen über Schwachstellen vielleicht erlangen diese Schwachstellen ausnutzen.
Und jetzt,
hat sich Peter wenn diese Schwachstelle ein unbekanntes Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum hat weil sie ja jeden Tag in dem Risiko steht gefunden zu werden und beseitigt zu werden kaufen unseres Hyper Krieger da nicht einfach heiße Luft,
weil die kaufen deshalb keine heiße Luft weiß ich natürlich die Schwachstelle sofort auf nutzen werden,
und zur Kompromittierung von Systemen nutzen werden um diese dann zu infizieren wichtig ist in diesem gesamten Bereich des fibres immer zu unterscheiden zwischen Schwachstelle Exploit,
und Infektion was erstmal relativ getrennte Dinge sind die Schwachstelle ist invitati schlummert
die wird dann entdeckt die Möglichkeit die Schwachstelle auszunutzen ist also dann irgendwie der Exploit irgendwie ein infektions two-line Übernahme tu irgendwas was diese Schwachstelle ausnutzt um sich des Systems zu bemächtigen.
Und dann kann ich ja quasi mit dem System vielleicht tun was ich möchte oder ich habe,
vielleicht im eingeschränkte Zugriffsmöglichkeiten auf das System aber ich habe es in irgendeiner Form kompromittiert und das erste was ich dann als Angreifer mache ist
das ist ihm infizieren so dass wenn jetzt ein Update kommt und die Schwachstelle Weg ist ich weiterhin mein Fuß in der Tür habe und das ist eigentlich das was ich auch immer genau zu diesem Thema versuche zu erklären wenn
wir dem Militär in irgendeiner Form heckbag Rechte geben dann werden die nicht erst den heckbag dann machen,
wenn das Bett ist sondern sie denn es vorher machen und die schädliche Hand,
im Rahmen des heckbag dann durchführen deswegen ist geht hier nur um es geht um offensiv Fähigkeiten und natürlich kannst du nicht einen Cyberkrieg gewinnen indem du sagst
heute ist Cyberkrieg alle Mann an die Tastatur holt die Exploits aus dem Keller und Cyber frei sondern du wirst vorher unterwandern.
Um dann quasi erst den Schaden zu haben dass du das okay wir sind jetzt schon drin und dann ebenso er Jungs erinnert ihr euch an das keine Ahnung an die Stromversorgung die war vor zehn Jahren unter unsere Kontrolle gebracht haben sind wir gerade noch in der Lage die zum
zum Einsturz zu bringen oder sowas ne solche Dinge für deine Rolle spielen wobei natürlich.
Stromversorgung in der öffentliche Infrastruktur Wer wer weiß also aber es geht auf jeden Fall und das ist das Problem an dieser ganzen Heckmeck Debatte ist,
kann nicht funktionieren wenn das heckbag erst zum Zeitpunkt erfolgt indem man sagt jetzt auf Kommando mal eben hacken der Gegner schläft nicht deswegen mistet man sich ein und hoffe dass man nicht entdeckt.
So viel,
dazu also die kaufen nicht heiße Luft sondern werden diese heiße Luft halt auch zur Anwendung bringen solange sie noch heiß.
Dann gab's noch Feedback zu,
ja dem jetzt schon eingangs angedeuteten Thema nämlich zur Debatte über den Gesetzgebungsprozess in der EU zu Artikel 13.
Da bekamen wir folgende Mail,
Artikel 13 bezieht sich auch in der aktuellen Fassung vom 13. Februar explizit auf Plattform deren Hauptzweck! Es ist nutzergenerierte Inhalte kommerziell zu verwehrt,
die Darstellung die teilweise auch bei Julia Räder zu finden ist es sein alle Plattform betroffen außer,
benny hat als drei Jahre online kleiner 10 Millionen Umsatz kleiner 5 minuten Zugriffe stimmt so nicht sowohl thematische Foren Blogs wir auch Wissensplattform Wikipedia und selbst kommerzielle Marktplätze wie Amazon sind nicht,
Bottrop.
Und da hilft auch ein Blick in den Text der vinylraider sogar selber fachlich hat.
Also nonprofit Online-Enzyklopädie erzieherische und wissenschaftliche Repositories,
quelloffene Software Entwicklungs und Plattformen also Getafe kommunikationsservice Anbieter,
online Handelsplätze und Business-to-Business Cloud-Services sind,
ausgeschlossen von der Direktive das ändert aber natürlich nichts daran dass upload-filter schlecht sind ich weiß jetzt nicht genau.
Bleibe dabei was bedeutet das für uns sind wir davon betroffen oder nicht sind wir eine Enzyklopädie nein sind wir ein wissenschaftliches Repository einige würden sagen ja.
Aber wir jetzt als pot.
Buchen.net will techno schwierig Zweifelsfall sind wir keine Plattform.
Na zumindest unsere Hauptzweck nicht nutzergenerierte Inhalte kommen erzählt zu verwerten.
Na da würde ich da will ich auch so ein bisschen widersprechenden da steht Hauptzweck,
oder einer der Hauptwerke.
Es ist zu speichern und verfügbar zu machen größere Mengen von Urheberrechts geschützten Werken,
geschützten Werken die hochgeladen werden von den Nutzern ja ist nicht unser Hauptzweck,
aber andererseits ich wir wir haben einen Urheberrecht auf unserer auf unseren Werken die welche offen obwohl nicht mittig veröffentlichen und das ist der Hauptzweck.
Ja alles mal vielleicht weil wir demnächst ja auch zu jedem Hörer Kommentar noch in der Werbung ansprechen.
Ja
Na ist doch schön dass es jetzt mit eine Limitierung gibt aber YouTube z.b. und andere große Plattform sind sehr wohl davon betroffen und auch das ist nicht okay.
Richtig das ist ein riesiges Problem und ich bleibe ja auch dabei dass ich das Kernproblem tatsächlich darin sehe wie diese uploadfilter,
eben von vielen nicht geleistet werden können wir sind jetzt übrigens direkt im Thema Artikel 13 da kannst du meine chaptermark setzen in unserer letzten Sendung am,
14. Februar haben wir uns damit schon auseinandergesetzt seitdem ist einiges geschehen.
Zunächst einmal gab es von der EU-Kommission,
auf Medium eine Plattform zum Teilen von Inhalten.
Deren Hauptzweck ist sie nur zeigen Hirten Inhalte erzählt sogar wert.
Ein ein Blogpost mit dem Titel the Copyright directive how the mob was told to save the dragon and Slay the night wie der Mops,
dazu gebracht wurde den Drachen zu retten und den Ritter zu töten zu schlachten in dem,
in einer Niete als würde ich am besten sagen nie da gewesen aber am liebsten bislang nie dagewesen und ohne Vergleich aber nein ist sowas ist auch schon da gewesen und sowas hat vergleiche.
Eine relativ langer Text darüber steht der im Prinzip sagt alle die gegen die Copyright Direktive sind wurden,
getäuscht ja Linktext censorship machines alles nicht richtig.
Brigit vielmehr darum hier Facebook und Google zu bekämpften die soviel Geld verdienen und diese Plattformen,
verdienen damit Geld und sind eine trillion Dollar wert und,
4WD Copyright directive jetzt level-playing-field schaffen was ich an diesem Text sehr schön oder sehr,
schlimm finde eigentlich ist das hier in keiner Form auf den Gesetzestext eingegangen wird ja ihr wird nicht erklärt schau mal so meinen wir das ja so und so ist es gedacht und deswegen also eine Argumentation am text,
passiert einfach nicht es einfach nur Behauptungen auch ohne Belege die hätten ja.
Das tun können ja und sie hätte ja sagen können guck mal der Text lautet so und so und deswegen ist diese und jene Behauptung falsch wie z.b. hier unser Feedback ja zu sagen alle Plattform,
ist nicht korrekt der Text lautet anders das hätten die ja hier tun können stattdessen schreiben Sie sogar in die besonders groß in in in orcad we are not banning means imgegenteil.de garantieren,
dass das Selbstausdruck stattfinden kann dieser Post das wiederum hat tatsächlich ein.
Ein wahrscheinlich ist beispiellos den haben die dann gelöscht,
bei der in der Mast um die Ohren geflogen ist also irgendwelche Vergleiche zu brexit Kampagnen und Bots und Mop und sonstigen gebracht haben wir es wirklich also
Menschen die sich hier seit Jahren mit diesem Thema versuchen informiert,
um auf juristischer Ebene auf ökonomischer Ebene auseinanderzusetzen auf diese Weise zu diffamieren das ist auf EU-Ebene in der Form hoffentlich,
ohne Beispiel wir werden sicherlich sehr viel in den in den Kommentaren und Ergänzung finden wo das schon mal passiert ist aber da ist es mir echt,
kalt den Rücken runter gelaufen mit diesem Blog.
Wer hat denn überhaupt verfasst.
Das habe ich auch versucht herauszufinden da steht einfach official official mediama count of EU Commission.
Steht jetzt kein direkter Autor mit dran.
Also ist Junkers.
Ja keine Ahnung wer das Ding wer den wirklich geschrieben hat.
Na ich meine wenn es niemand anders drin steht und ist die Kommission alles halt ums Haus weil der Chef schuld.
Ja also Zweifelsfall der Chef will mit der Formulierung,
frage dich selbst qui Bono.
Voll die Verschwörungstheorie Maschine her.
Unglaublich ja und David sehen wir eben auch auf welchem Niveau diese Debatte jetzt gelandet ist,
doch es kommt natürlich noch schlimmer doch der Reihe nach am 18.03 wurde da.
Und das Ergebnis oder des der Zwischenstand ein Laon line Petition an Justizministerin barley übergeben,
diese Online-Petition war auf change.org gestartet worden und hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt am 18.3 4,7 Millionen Unterschrift.
Und dann gabs halt wie man das dann so macht dann gibt's eben da wohnen die alle ausgedruckt und dann sind sie dahin und haben sie ein Termin bei Frau bahle gehabt und haben mir das Ding in die Hand gedrückt und das übergeben,
und Frau Bali hat sich dann irgendwie berührt gezeigt von diesem wunderbaren Akt der außer metallischer parlamentarischen Demokratie ja und.
Julia Reda sagte dann natürlich auch noch dazu das Justizministerium ist für das Urheberrecht zuständig und am Mittwoch.
Nämlich gestern am 20 Februar wurde im Rat über diese Sache abgestimmt und hier hätte unsere Justizministerin sagen können hey das hier ist mein Resort ich bin verantwortlich hier rad Pipapo wir stimmen,
dagegen welchen Grund hätte sie gehabt dagegen zustimmt beispielsweise den Koalitionsvertrag zwischen CDU CSU und SPD,
verfasst 2018 in dem besteht eine Verpflichtung von Plattformen zum Einsatz von Upload filtern um von Nutzern hochgeladenen Inhalte nach Urheberrechtsverletzung Inhalten zu filtern lehnen wir als unverhältnismäßig.
Jetzt findet das jetzt kommt noch besser am 20 Uhr wurde es also im Rat durchgewunken wer war dagegen wer hat dagegen gestimmt.
Italien Finnland Luxemburg die Niederlande und Polen und haben gesagt wir stimmen der Gegenteil.
Das nun im Trialog im Trilog ausgehandelte Paket steht genau keine angemessene Balance,
zwischen dem Schutz der Rechteinhaber und den Interessen individueller Bürger,
Herr es fehlt außerdem nötige rechtliche Klarheit.
Und deswegen wenn rechtliche Kleid nicht da ist dann für das erst recht zu Grundrechtseingriffe ein Grundrecht Gefährdungen für die,
Nutzer sagen also abschließen das ursprüngliche Ziel den digitalen Binnenmarkt und die Innovation zu stärken ist im Laufe der Verhandlungen aus den Augen geraten
dem würde ich vollkommen zustimmen da können wir auch nur wiederholen dass Julia Reder die ich habe mal geschaut zu diesem Thema Kunst dreimal Gas war er die Wahl ich glaube am Folge 127 mit welche Folgen war das denn noch.
Folge und wer bist du denn,
tschuldigung Folge 150 Folge 239 und Folge 259 hatten wir Julia Reda im Prinzip zu diesem Thema da bei uns in der Sendung sie verfolgt das,
seither und selbst Julia Räder die in dieses Thema,
am ausführlichsten begleitet sagt ja wir brauchen dringend eine Copyright Reform sind alle super es geht ja nur um diesen Artikel 11 und um diesen Artikel 13 der bestenfalls ersatzlos gestrichen werden.
Jetzt geht der gute Herford hin und sagt,
auf Twitter und in diversen Interviews der steht da überhaupt nichts von uploadfilter wird mal Steuerung App Filter findest du nicht.
Und auch das stimmt denn es ist noch viel schlimmer der Wortlaut von Artikel 13,
ist sogar nicht nur dass sie Filtern müssen sondern sie müssen eine Autorisierung der Rechteinhaber,
die in Artikel 3 Absatz 1 und 2 der definiere Direktive definiert sind.
Bekommen z.b. indem es in der feine Form von licensing agreement gibt.
Damit sie diese Werke überhaupt öffentlich machen können.
Ich habe gehört ihr Thomas Stadler der Jever geschätzte Jurist von internet-law die Anbieter sollen also jetzt nicht mehr nur eine Veröffentlichung ohne Zustimmung des Rechteinhabers.
Das hättest nämlich erforderlich gemacht die viel diskutierten uploadfilter einzuführen nach diesem aktuellen Konzept sollen die Plattformbetreiber fiel mir gleich direkt beim Rechteinhaber eine Lizenz erwerben damit sind also selbst,
uploadfilter nicht mehr zwingend geeignet diese Gesetz zu ende.
Bzw sie uploadfilter müssen im Prinzip die nächste technische Stufe machen und automatisch.
Willingen Billinger willingrade.
Genau ein billigen oder so eine Notification automatisch so als nicht nur das man selber feststellt oder es ist jetzt hier sozusagen nehmen Material sondern das ja Vergleich bei Constantin Film Fax,
hinschicken soll mit hier bitte einmal die Erlaubnis euch Geld überweisen zu dürfen.
Genau du hättest du müsstest also Lizenz würde ja bedeuten wenn du zahlst jetzt ein bestimmten Betrag im Zweifelsfall eines du dich auf ne
auf eine Flatrate oder fragt Fragment eines Cent pro Ausstrahlung oder sonstigen und erkennst das erkennt automatisch einer das ist Urheberrecht geschützt ist Material,
das können wir nicht veröffentlichen weil uns die,
Lizenzen fehlen und hier haben wir einen lizenz-deal und deswegen kann das jetzt veröffentlichen weißt du woran das sehr erinnert an die sperr Tafeln die ist bei YouTube lange Zeit gab.
Wegen der Einigung oder nicht Einigung mit der GEMA ein langjähriges leid das ist im Prinzip das worauf sich das bezieht na sind nicht nur
musst du Urheberrechtsverletzung blocken sondern du solltest im Prinzip auch noch hinzukommen eine Lizenzvereinbarung.
Mit den Rechteinhabern haben also völlig völlig abgehoben,
bis zu einem Punkt wo US-Amerikaner jetzt inzwischen sagen so wenn die EU so weitermacht ne,
dann haben wir bald EU EU Internet und US Internet weil.
Datenschutz Regulation Copyright Regulation dass wir dann irgendwann inkompatibel.
Na gut meine dsgvo haben wir das im Prinzip jetzt auch schon diesen Split und China natürlich er sein eigenes Internet also das ist natürlich der Trend dass das Internet so ein bisschen an Inter ein anderer sein also ich weiß gerade nicht ob es,
falsch mir gerade durch den Kopf schiebe also was ich generell hier.
Überhaupt schon mal ganz unabhängig von den Fakten die hier auf den Tisch legen kritisiere ist das jetzt im Trilog also dem undemokratischen Teil des gesamten EU-Gesetz Prozesse.
Für diese Urheberrechtsreform jetzt hier vollkommen neue Verfahren erfunden werden die so ein Parlament nie behandelt.
Aber deswegen geht's ja auch noch mal zurück ins Parlament.
Ja okay gut das wäre dann natürlich sehen das könnte insofern natürlich auch bedeuten dass das Parlament jetzt noch weitere Argumente zu sagen,
sorry aber das entspricht nicht nur nicht unseren Vorstellungen so anders das ist einfach auch noch mal was ganz
anderes darüber dass wir nie debattiert haben das können wir gar nicht suchen ob das soweit kommen wird das werden wir ja sehen halte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt für wahrscheinlich aber auch nicht für komplett,
außergewöhnlich andererseits erstmal die Idee hier so ein bisschen mal aufzugreifen,
schalt das ja hier außer der technische schönen Lösung anzumahnen dies so erstmal auch noch gar nicht gibt wo Urheberrecht,
Automatiken irgendwie gebaut werden weil,
alle schon viel Diskussion darüber geführt und das ist so ein mega weitesfeld so aber so diese diese Pflicht einer Registrierung für Urheberschaft ja.
Tim das wird dass wir mit der künstlichen Intelligenz alles in Ordnung kommen hat uns doch ist so.
Ist die künstliche Intelligenz.
Er hat uns die GEMA gestern relativ einfach erklärt GEMA News einen Twitter-Account mit blauen Häkchen von der GEMA und die schreiben ernsthaft nach mir gezwitschert künstliche Intelligenz kann heute Gesichter erkennen,
Vorlieben herausfiltern und sogar selbstständig einparken da sollte es ein Leichtes sein zwischen Original und Parodie zu unterscheiden,
deshalb sage die die uns irgendwie weiß ich innerhalb 14 Sporthafen beschert hat also.
Schiller Kommentar.
Ich weiß nicht wo ich anfangen soll eine künstliche Intelligenz Muster ganz kurz mal einen kleinen Ausflug.
Hatte Albers Kommentar dazu gesehen aber Freude meinte nur was künstlich intelligente heißen muss auch schlau und intelligent sein Zitronenfalter Falten doch auch Zitronen.
Künstliche Intelligenz.
Ist ja sowieso gerade so ein ein ein passwort passwort sondergleichen.
Ja blockchain lässt nach.
Und es ist wirklich sehr anstrengend zu sehen was.
Irgendwelche sachfremden Menschen diesen verpaaren alles zutrauen ja also so die die Komplexität ein Fahrzeug einzupacken,
ist natürlich in keiner Form zu vergleichen mit der Komplexität zu erkennen was ist original was ist
Parodie vorallem weil dieses Parodie eben sich in einer Grauzone befindet sie treffen quasi genau diese Kerbe das genau diese eine Unterscheidung unglaublich schwierig ist.
Genau das keine Frage von Intelligenz sondern Frage von von Auslegung ist werden ohnehin,
sehr umstritten ist ob die Verfahren der künstlichen Intelligenz überhaupt intelligent sind nazon oder ob es sich da nicht viel mehr wie man unter Fachleuten diese Verfahren nennt um,
maschinelles Lernen handelt statt um künstlich Intelligenz also wirklich eine 1.
Eines von vielen Paradebeispiel dafür wie,
fernab von jedem Verständnis des Sachverhaltes diese Diskussionen stattfinden weitere Punkte sehr wichtig ist.
Alle diskutieren jetzt nur noch über Artikel 13 das liegt ein bisschen daran dass ja der uploadfilter natürlich irgendwie.
Furchteinflößender ist als ein Leistungsschutzrecht darf aber nicht vergessen dass dieser Artikel 11,
ebenso beknackt ist wie das Leistungsschutzrecht was wir in Deutschland ja schon haben.
Denn hier wird formuliert die Reproduktion von mehr als einzelnen Wörtern Worten oder sehr kurzen Extrakten von stories.
Verlangt nach einer Lizenz es gibt keine Ausnahmen weder für Individuen kleine Unternehmen nonprofit für alle,
also einen Hardcore Leistungsschutzrecht zum Schutz der Presseverlage,
das hier hinten im im Fahrwasser dieser gesamten Artikel 13 Debatten ankommt,
über diese Unterrichtsform Thema gerade schon angekündigt wird dann noch mal,
im EU Parlament abgestimmt dass er das Ende des trilogues ist ja das vermengte Gebilde geht dann zurück ins Parlament und da muss dann darüber abgestimmt werden noch einmal,
und das soll voraussichtlich Ende März im Parlament passieren so das heißt mit der Entscheidung des Rates ist es jetzt wirklich damit natürlich schon oft über die Jahre,
gesagt das ist jetzt für die letzte eine der eine der letzten österlichen Hürden ja überhaupt das dass Axel Voss damals diesen Text als Vorschlag in den,
Trilog bekommen hat als Berichterstatter des EU Parlamentes war ein fürchterlicher Moment ja.
Aber diese Entscheidung des Rates nun das hier zurückzugehen als EU-Parlament war wirklich die letzte der letzte. Mit dieser Entscheidung Ende März im EU Parlament ist es,
durch oder nicht.
Deswegen hat sich jetzt angekündigt für den 23.03 ein europaweiter Protest da werden wir hier regelmäßig noch bis dahin darauf aufmerksam machen wann und wo der stattfindet.
In vielen Städten europaweit das heißt da wird entsprechend sicherlich sehr viele Demonstrationen geben und es ist sehr wichtig an dieser Stelle,
den den Protest auf die Straße zu tragen denn wo auch immer wir ihn bisher hin getragen haben ist er ja verheilt.
Aber da sind wir das nicht auch schon sehr nah,
an dem voraussichtlichen abstimmungsdatum und deswegen geht es jetzt am,
zweiten dritten schon einmal los in,
mit einer Demonstration dazu das ist nicht die erste gab in der letzten Woche schon eine in Köln wo spontan immerhin,
grub 1 bis 2000 Leute demonstriert haben mit dem wunderschönen Motto wir sind die Bots.
Und dort ihren,
ihren ihren Missfallen gezeigt haben und ich bin sehr gespannt wie sich das jetzt entwickelt weil diese dieses gesamte YouTube Ökosystem hat sich bisher selten,
politisch positioniert in einer sei mal so geschlossener Form ne da.
Genau da war das war das dass der erst das erste Beispiel und dann gibt's natürlich gibt's politische Sendungen auf YouTube aber das soll jetzt quasi und ihr wählt die Kanzlerin hat sich doch auch von dem einen.
Der mit der Mütze LeFloid von diesem LeFloid unter untersuchen lassen.
Interviewen lassen.
Beugen Sie sich doch mal vor.
Hat sich von LeFloid untersuchen lassen.
Ja das war ja.
Dass die jetzt.
Aber jetzt in dieser Form ist es jetzt europaweit das natürlich noch mal Faktoren wie Alter damals auch.
Die stehen quasi geschlossen und da kann dir jetzt,
können wir hoffentlich noch mal irgendwie eine Mobilisierung sehen im Netz politischen Bereich die da vielleicht in diesem Ausmaß lange nicht mehr hatten darauf dass auf jeden Fall meine Hoffnung in Berlin,
ruft das Demo Bündnis Berlin gegen 13 Uhr für den 23 auf es geht,
los vor dem Axel Springer Hochhaus dann über die Friedrichstraße zum Justizministerium und dann über die
Friedrichstraße Unter den Linden zur Vertretung der EU-Kommission am Brandenburger Tor Beginn 13 Uhr,
und diese Demonstration ist jetzt angemeldet wird stattfinden und da können wir euch herzlich zu einladen diesen kleinen Spaziergang,
durch die historischen ist das historische Zentrum Berlins und die wichtigen,
Werkstätten daran teilzunehmen.
Fantasiere mit dieser dieser Mangel der Politisierung unserer Jugend wird ja immer viel debattiert und gewisser Hinsicht finde ich auch schade dass das immer nur bei
wir können unsere Videos nicht mehr bei YouTube hochladen Themen zur Sprache kommt aber immerhin vielleicht bewirkt es ja auch lang.
Ja also natürlich ist das auf eine gewisse Weise hier,
kann man jetzt irgendwie kritisieren die Youtuber sind betroffen die Youtuber haben eine Gefolgschaft,
die Youtuber mobilisieren für Ihre Interesse.
Andererseits ist es doch auch gut dass die Youtuber in diesem Fall mobilisieren und nicht irgendwie in jedem Fall ja insofern finde ich das überhaupt nicht,
dramatische ich meine die die flach erdler mobilisieren für die flache Erde und das auch in Ordnung und hier gibt's jetzt ein breites Bündnis,
weil die eben alle betroffen sind finde ich nachvollziehbar.
Und in gewisser Form auch gut dass die Youtuber in dieser Breite im auch nur für ihre spezifischen Interessen mobilisieren und nicht irgendwie die Übernahme ins ins Haus.
Ja also nimmt an den Demonstrationen teil markiert euch den 23.03 der fällt glaube ich oft die zum Scribe in Köln das heißt ihr könnt jetzt auch ne Konferenz geben.
Du weißt ja nicht mal wann deiner eigenen Veranstaltungen sind oder was.
Der 23 ist der Sams.
Kannst du direkt mal.
Da laufen wir dann genau auf der Konferenz an im Kreis halt Schildau.
Könnte auch die Demonstration direkt bei euch beim WDR anmelden Deutschlandfunk umso besser hatte Presse direkt vor Ort.
Stimmt müssen die nicht so weit fahren haltet einfach mal kurz die Mikrofone drauf fertig.
Also jetzt ist jetzt ist es an der Zeit die die Demonstrationen anzumelden anzustrengen und zuzusehen.
Trauerspiel ehrlichgesagt wie sich das entwickelt also diese.
Sollen wir noch was zu dem Thema glaube am alles erwähnt.
Da wäre alles Wichtige gesagt 2. 3. 23.3.
Ja die Bots ne.
Wir sind die Bots.
Alle sind Bots.
Alles alles voller Bots dieses Thema social Bots lässt uns ja irgendwie nicht los.
Ich habe das inzwischen eine schon fast zu den Akten gelegt aber vor kurzem,
schalte dieses Thema social Bots wieder hoch und hat bin ich auf ein YouTube-Video aufmerksam geworden wie ich im Deutschen Bundestag da mal kurz meine Meinung zu dem
zu der Idee social Bots und Wahlmanipulation vertreten durfte,
Anwaltskanzlei interessiert würde sagen diese Äußerungen dich da getätigt habe sind ganz gut gealtert aber da habe ich glaube ich relativ.
Treffsicher bisschen dazu gesprochen zu diesem Thema.
Was ist wahrscheinlich jetzt zwei Jahre her oder so können wir ja in die Scheune auslegen dieses Video.
Ja mach mal das kann ich noch nicht drin.
Es gab jetzt wieder eine neue Studie eine Studie der Universität Duisburg-Essen Projektleiter Björn Ross und die Studie trägt den Titel,
are social Bots aerial Threat sind sie eine Bedrohung oder nicht und.
Was sie gemacht haben ist sie haben gesagt okay es gibt eine Theorie der Schweigespirale diese Theorie der Schweigespirale besagt wenn du mit ausreichend konträren Meinungen,
konfrontiert wirst dann hörst du ihr mal auf deine eigene zu sagen du änderst sie vielleicht nicht.
Aber quasi die andere,
die überwiegende Meinung nimmt dann in der Äußerung auch noch mal überproportional überhand und.
Diese Theorie ist in den Kommunikationswissenschaften ganz gut elaboriert und jetzt haben die gesagt jetzt würden wir natürlich gerne prüfen ob social Bots,
Indian Theiner Form dieser Theorie zu Wirkung verhelfen können erstmal eine nicht blöde.
Studien Frage stellt sich natürlich aber die Frage wie kann man das jetzt realisieren im Prinzip and experiment in der freien Wildbahn ist nicht möglich und ethisch auch nicht vertretbar was macht man also haben die gesagt na ja okay.
Wir bauen jetzt bot.
Und modellieren dass diese bot sich gemäß der Theorie der Spirale des Schweigens verhalten.
Und dann haben sie diese Box ausgestattet mit du hast Meinung a du hast Meinung B und haben die quasi virtuell in ein Kommunikationsnetzwerk getan in ein soziales Netzwerk der andere ist ein soziales Netzwerk von nur Bots.
Wer war kein einziger Mensch dran beteiligt und die Bots waren so programmiert dass sie sich gemäß der Theorie Verhalten haben sogar evaluiert immer gesagt die bauen jetzt Botz die müssen sich so zu verhalten,
und dann haben sie,
einige andere Boxer reingemacht die ähm wie das Kommunikationsverhalten übermäßig gezeigt haben und haben festgestellt die anderen Boards die wir programmiert haben dass sie sich gemäß der Spirale des Schweigens Verhalten weiß was die gemacht haben.
Die haben sich gemäß der Spirale des Schweigens verhalten.
Wirklich ist ja jetzt unfassbar.
Wahnsinn ein Experiment von von das keinen anderen Ausgang hätte haben können weil die die Box programmiert haben sich so zu verhalten Sie sich verhalten haben.
Ja weil.
Das ist künstliche Intelligenz und deswegen brauchen wir auch künstliche Intelligenz damit solche Stoss Studien nicht mehr stattfinden ja gesagt also dann stellt er fest,
das hängt von drei Faktoren ab.
Wie erfolgreich die Bots Einfluss nehmen hängt von drei Faktoren ab erstens wie viele Verbindung gibt es zwischen den Nutzern eines Netzwerks zweitens wo werden die Bots in diesem Netzwerk platziert zentral oder am Rand,
und sind sie so gut programmiert dass sie wie ein Mensch agieren das ergibt sich aus den Parametern deines Modells du Vollidiot also da ist wirklich der der nichts bewiesen hat einfach nur gesagt wir nehmen eine der neben einem Modell,
oder wir nehmen eine wissenschaftlich ganz gut unterfütterte Theorien bauen Computerprogramme die sich danach verhalten und stellen nachher fest dass das was wir programmiert haben auch tatsächlich funktioniert hat,
und damit ist der Typ irgendwie oder es ist diese diese Gruppe durch.
Sind durch irgendwie Medien Masten marschiert und du kommst wirklich aus dem aus dem fazial palmieren nicht mehr raus ja.
Weißt du schon erstaunlich ist dass es wird geschafft haben nach ihren eigenen Vorgaben Software zu erstellen die dann auch genau das tut was die Vorgaben gesagt haben das schafft auch nicht hier.
Dafür gebührt in jeder Respekt also Respekt,
aber diese diese Studie ist natürlich ohne jegliche empirische Relevanz sie sagen jetzt also ist erstaunlich was hier in ihrer Studie zitieren ist na ja.
Erstaunlich wie wenig Potzmann braucht aber diese Studie lässt sich in so vielen,
in so vielen Faktoren nicht in die reale Welt übertragen erstens
das waren robots das waren keine Menschen du weißt ja nicht was ein Mensch den ganzen anderen Tag mit seiner Aufmerksamkeit macht in den sozialen Netzwerken haben wir allerlei Mechanismen Iris im Prinzip davor schützen dass irgendeiner uns an quatscht
wir diskutieren über diskutieren über Gott und die Welt wir gucken uns irgendwie Sachen zu unseren Hobbys an wir gucken abends noch ein paar YouTube Videos,
irgendwo gibt es auch mal einen Bot ob der mich überhaupt erreicht in meinem,
ist die Frage ja ich habe in der Giuliano weiß das ja nicht du weißt ja nicht vielleicht ist ja was was ich etwas hallo wo ein Bad hast du nicht.
Bettenset Andy nutze vereinbart.
Ist es sogar hab ich ja gesagt es sind das war auch glaube ich in dieser in dieser Anhörung es ist ja ein Hybrid,
teilweise pizzateam linuzifer.
Aha.
Python Script Wasser perfide mit uns kommuniziert also ist wirklich so was es uns echt nicht geholfen.
Manches ist wahr anderes könnte vielleicht nicht falsch sein.
Einige Links könnten ins Internet führen.
Oder zu einer allgemeinen Verunsicherung.
Also es ist es ist wirklich nicht geholfen wenn wir,
auf diese Weise und der uns diesen Themen nähern und da ihr welche Leute ein paar Sachen testen und dann sagen na ja so das haben wir rausgefunden ist ja klar also das hattie-studie teste nicht machen müssen.
Ich merke schon dein Vertrauen in Softwaresysteme ist eingeschränkt Linus warum nur warum nur warum nur dabei gibt es doch so hervorragende technologische Neuentwicklung wie z.b. das timer Voting.
Berufskrankheit glaube ich wenn man sich oft genug mit Aldi System und ihren Fehlern auseinandersetzt verliert man irgendwann das Vertrauen das noch mal was vernünftig funktionieren könnte sie haben letzte Woche schon.
Darüber gesprochen dass die Schweizer Post ja gesagt hat hier es gibt jetzt die haben das nicht pentest genannt sondern irgendwie,
intrusion Test oder sowas her und sagt ja,
haben ja ausgelobt so jetzt gibt's vier Wochen Zeit da könnt ihr unser System hier prüfen und danach ist es dann sicher ne also dieses klassische
kommt ihr Spackos meldet uns mal kurz ein paar Sicherheitslücken wenn wenn ihr welche findet dann schließen wir die und dann können wir abschließend sagen dass dass das System jetzt einsatzbereit ist.
Und du konntest um an diesen an diesem dieser Aufforderung teilzunehmen bekommst du auch den Einsicht in den Quellcode dieses System ist und.
Um das um diesen Zugriff zu bekommen musstest du aber die Nutzungsbestimmungen akzeptieren und in diesen Nutzungsbestimmungen steht 9 Uhr ausgeschlossen vom Test sind,
Angriffe die darauf abzielen mit Last basierten Angriffen die Stimmabgabe zu verunmöglichen,
Angriffe die darauf abzielen wir wir gefälschter nachrichten die Akteure dazu zu bringen von den vorgesehenen Prozessen abzuweichen in Klammern social-engineering C,
Angriffe die darauf abzielen Stimmen zu manipulieren sofern der Angriff mit Hilfe der individuellen Verifizierbarkeit erkannt werden,
die Angriffe die darauf abzielen Stimmen zu lesen indem Malware auf die zur Stimmabgabe verwendeten Geräte verbreitet wird
Angriffe auf Dienstleistung des Systemanbieter der nicht mit Cybermobbing in Verbindung steht,
Angriffe auf das System zum elektronischen Versand der Stimmrechtsausweis das ist sehr interessant.
Wir haben ja sechs Ausschlüsse wo sie sagen das ist drin in einem pentest definiert man einen scope das ist auch richtig so ja man sagt wir wir wir wollen folgende Formen von Angriffen prüfen,
und folgendes nicht einfach damit du ein klares Ziel hast das Interessante ist aber dass diese diese sechs Angriffe diese da anders Arten diese auflisten,
sind außerhalb ihrer Kontrolle das heißt gegen die Version ich tun können und die nehmen sie quasi als gegeben hin,
und das ist aber dass es diese Angriffe gibt und dass sie nicht Teil dieses des Scopes das Band testet ist schon dass die Kapitulation das ist die Kapitulation.
Das deutsche Volk Medi Kapitulation braucht die Engländer und das ist.
Kommst auch da nicht aus dem Gesicht klatschen raus.
Ja das ist sowieso alsbald verhindern dass er das hier von irgendjemand nass gemacht werden aber bei ihren Test schließen sie halt Wetter und Wind komplett aus weil das also ne.
Unsere Uhr ist wasserdicht ausgeschlossen sind es die darauf abzielen die Uhr in ein Wasserbad einzuführen.
Oder länger als eine Sekunde ob darin zu belassen.
Unglaublich und man musste sich eben ausführlicher Nutzungsbeschränkung runter unterwerfen um überhaupt Zugriff auf diesen Quelltext zu bekommen der ist aber dann relativ flott auf,
Gitter gelandet wo er jetzt also allgemein zugänglich ist und dann ein paar Leute,
mal ein Blick drauf geworfen unter anderem rEDGREEN Professor für Kryptographie dessen Urteil nach kurzer nach kurzen Blick war,
ich hasse so etwas das sind eindeutig Idioten die keine Idee haben was sie da tun aber sie haben,
ausreichend genug Deckung,
um nachher behaupten zu können dass es nur Test code war und dass es bei der bei der echten,
weil dann etwas anderes zum Einsatz kommt ja also genau das was sie jetzt was sie hier jetzt machen quasi alles was jetzt da an an,
an Schwachstellen und an Problem gefunden wird er sie dann gar wunderbar haben wir behoben und am Ende wollen sie den ganzen Mist dann doch in einer in einer Wahl aus und ich find's halt,
es ist bezeichnet ja ausgeschlossen vom Test sind und diese sechs wunderschönen aufgelisteten angriffsvektoren die hast du nicht bei einer echten Wahl die hast du einfach nicht.
Wie hast du die kaufst du dir neu dazu.
Das ist wirklich zum Heulen also insofern die Bemühungen und der für das Schweizer Cybermobbing Moratorium nach wie vor volle Unterstützung.
Chaos Computer Club Schweiz ist da stark involviert aber nicht die einzige Gruppierung in diesem Bündnis und wir können euch nach wie vor nur.
Bitten daran mitzuwirken dass in irgendeiner Form darauf.
Inga arbeitet für das diesen wieder einmal Demokratie gefährden Unsinn ein ein Ende bereitet.
Sonst interessant fand ich ja. Ja also dieser Ausschluss Angriffe auf Dienstleistung des Systemanbieter sie nicht mit evote in Verbindung stehen.
Such mal so diese Systemanbieter diese Firmen die dann den ganzen Krempel da so hinstellen,
keiner hat ein besseren Zugriff auf diese Systeme keiner kann besser entweder selber Manipulation vornehmen oder Manipulation,
vor der Aufdeckung bewahren bzw diese Dienstleistung des Systemanbieter haben ja auch was mit Mitarbeitern zu tun und diese Mitarbeiter können natürlich relativ einfach auch unter Druck gesetzt werden,
und das ist alles solche Vektoren die muss man je miteinbeziehen und genau das ist ja das Kernproblem dem Moment wo man den Prozess elektronifizierung.
Nimmt man eben die Möglichkeit weg das Ganze unter Kontrolle.
Und selbstverständlich hackst du als erstes den Admin.
Klar der hat dass der Typ RP zahlen da ins Webroot kopiert dann nehmen wir doch mal einfach dessen Zugangsrechte und ändern bisschen was da dran ist doch gar kein Thema hier.
Ja oder man fährt halt irgendwie,
irgendwo vor und bedroht ein wenig die Familie oder keine Ahnung sitzt andere Personen auf sie anderen alles Maßnahmen aus dem klassischen Handbuch aller Geheimdienste,
und wie und das weiß ich aber das schon so erwähnt haben, vielleicht auch noch mal sagen diese ganzen sinnlosen Vergleiche mit,
ja hier ist halber Voting und so viel benutzt noch überall auch Computer und wenn man damit Geld transferieren kann,
welchen Wert die Einflussnahme auf eine Wahl,
hat kann man sehr schön sehen an dieser Intensität die Russland entwickelt hat um Einfluss auf die amerikanischen Wahlen und natürlich auch brexit und so weiter zu nehmen das long-term gehen und dass das.
Da sind ein paar Millionen Dollar Kai das einfach Portokasse,
die schmeißt du da einfach mal mit rein weil der Nutzen den du daraus ziehen kannst wenn du da auch nur irgendein busines Stil größerer Natur später machen kannst weil im passende Machthaber nach vorne gebracht hast,
ist also ganze Investition wert das heißt hier ist im Prinzip unbegrenzt viel Geld vorhanden um das System zu attackieren bekannter,
1000 elektronische Sicherheitsmaßnahmen Audits und blauäugige Technologen am Start haben am Ende können die sich dagegen nicht werden deswegen muss alles in der Öffentlichkeit sein,
so öffentlich wie es nur irgendwie geht und das heißt,
raus aus den Computern Papier Papier Papier Papier und alles ist super und waren es gibt kein Problem mit Papieren sowie auch immer mal wieder klar machen.
Es gibt hier kein Problem zu.
Kein es gibt kein Problem zu lösen mit dem Computer Mannschaft sich nur weg.
Zumal.
Die wo ich schon mal da das haben sie noch nicht mal drin der genau das ist die Malware.
Dieser quattro wir erkennen an dass die zur Stimmabgabe verwendeten Geräte unsicher sind,
aber diese auch diese Unsicherheit ist außerhalb unseres Raubs hört ihr Leute wählen ja mit ihren muss ja überlegen diese Leute will ja dann am Ende hier mit ihrem Internet Explorer 7,
kriegen wir die Werbung weg damit sie wählen könnten und allein das,
reicht schon aus um zu sagen nein das kann nicht sicher sein weil das Stimmabgabe Gerät deine Wahlkabine ist dein kaputtes Android.
Ende der Geschichte und auch das ist hier wieder ausgeschlossen also das sind die Risiken die sie alle sehenden Auges mit mit,
mit aufnehmen sag ja ja die übrigens aber das ist klar das ist klar Tim das brauchen wir das ist aber ausgeschlossen ist wenig Tims.
Aber eigentlich gute Nachrichten ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich.
Gartner eine Anhörung zur zu 5g in,
im im Bundestagsausschuss welcher Ausschuss war das denn jetzt noch mal schauen Bundestag.
Sachverständiger Sohn bundestagsanhörung ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie Ausschuss digitale Agenda.
Interessant mich eine Wissenslücke jedenfalls.
Waren dort mehrere Sachverständige vor Ort unter anderem für den Chaos Computer Club Michael Horn der sagte.
Lokales Roaming ist zwar mit erträglichen Aufwand schnell umsetzbar ist aber kein nachhaltiges Konzept besser wäre es.
Bitte mal kurz erklären was damit gemeint.
Lokales Roaming hatten wir in der Sendung erklärt mit Thomas Rudel wo im Prinzip die Annahme ist jetzt hat
Netzanbieter irgendwie sein Netz gebaut Netzanbieter B in weiten Teilen überschneiden diesig und jetzt gibt es Bereiche die deckt nur a ab und es gibt Bereiche die denkt nur b ab
und jetzt kommt aber ein Nutzer des Mobilfunknetzes a in den Bereich den UB abdeckt was passiert jetzt hat er keinen Empfang mehr.
Oder so ist es ja geplant kann nun der Netzbetreiber B verpflichtet werden,
Soja die Planung von der Bundesnetzagentur den.
Kunden von Netzanbieter auch die Nutzung seines Netzes zu ermöglichen.
Am ähnlich wie das ist wenn ihr ins Ausland Fahrt da hat Telekom dann auch kein Netz mehr und
Nutztier eben das Netz eines anderen Anbieters und da gibt's dann irgendwie Regelungen darüber wie die das unter sich finanziell klären jetzt könnt ihr mal die Leute sogar verpflichten zum lokalen Roaming und sein muss auch kostenlos möglich sein dass,
löst aber nicht das Problem dass sie trotzdem beide überhaupt ein Mobilfunknetz bauen müssen.
Und deswegen die Empfehlung besser wäre es wenn Infrastrukturen und Standorte gibt halt würden sie etwa in Polen,
so geht es langfristig geht auch gar nicht anders um weiße Flecken zu schließen was ist der Unterschied der Unterschied ist hier statt überhaupt zwei Netze zu bauen,
indem du sagst jetzt kann der eine mal an 1 an lokalen stellen Gast im anderen Netz sein relativ komplex übrigens dann natürlich auch in der Abrechnung Roaming hat in der Vergangenheit ausführliche Probleme auch gebracht,
in der Sicherheit von Mobilfunknetzen ja viele der abhör und lokalisierungs Angriffe funktioniert denn deshalb weil es ein interconnect gibt weil es dieses Roaming gibt
klüger du baust direkt das nicht so dass die die Infrastruktur geteilt wird ist ganz nett ist von vorne rein gebaut den Kunden A und B
am Zugang zu geben und genau das wird wurde mit 4G und jetzt mit dem Schritt zu 5g auch sehr sehr stark ermöglicht du kannst also Ressourcen flexibler aufteilen und die Dienste die tatsächlich,
darüber stattfinden von dem Netzbetrieb trennen was jetzt in 2G 3G Netzen gar nicht so einfach.
Wo der kann sie alles.
In 5g ist daraufhin optimiert dass das die Sachen sauberer getrennt sind und dass du so etwas tun könntest aber natürlich das wird hier nicht.
Bitte auch wieder verheilen aber wenigstens hat der Chaos Computer Club hier seine.
Kompetenz und Empfehlungen eingebracht in das Parlament und wir können es jetzt wieder anschauen wie.
Das alles ignoriert wird.
Das weiß gar nicht so eine schlecht.
Na immerhin man kommt zu Wort.
Auch schon öfter erwähnt von uns ist das iPad Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 steht vor der Tür.
Nur 20.
Reinhold ja 10 ist ja jetzt gerade mal ich gleich wird jetzt schätzen 3 oder 4 Jahre.
Aber heutzutage muss man doch schon auf 4.06 wenn die Industrie schon 40.
Ja aber musst du kannst ja nicht einfach du musst jetzt neu erstmal und 2.0 und 3.0 unten 3.11 Workgroups durchbringen bevor du irgendwann 4.0 machen kann.
ART Sicherheitsgesetz 311 Firma Krups wird gut.
So präzise ist diese wir warten ja schon darauf und man merkt die,
die laufen sich gerade warm ja die laufen sich gerade warm weil im Prinzip muss dieses Gesetz wird gerade schon geschrieben,
kann so ungefähr dir ausrechnen wenn das irgendwie dieses Jahr noch kommen soll dann sind Sie gerade dabei und in Berlin war jetzt gerade der oder ist vielleicht sogar immer noch der europäische Polizeikongress,
der wenn ich mich nicht täusche im BCC stattfindet wo wir auch früher den Kongress immer gemacht haben.
Da werden natürlich jetzt schon die die schönen Forderungen so ein bisschen gebracht ne,
erweiterte Befugnisse für Sicherheitsbehörden
BKA-Chef Holger Münch legt einmal vor was er so gerne alles möchte Neville kriege jetzt sowieso von der EU bald offenbart verpflichtete Speicherung von Fingerabdrücken im Personalausweisen damit natürlich auch die
zentrale Speicherung der Fingerabdruck an irgendeiner Stelle wie wir wollen irgendwas gegen Terror machen und so weiter.
Das Darknet soll direkt mal verboten werden ja auch wunderschön da trittst dann wer war das.
Günter Krings parlamentarischer Staatssekretär im Bundesinnenministerium stellt sich davor den europäischen Polizeikongress und sagt ich verstehe.
Warum das Darknet einen Nutzen in autokratischen Systemen haben kann aber in einer freien offenen Demokratie gibt es meiner Meinung nach keinen legitimen nutzen.
Wer das sagt nicht nutzt führt in der Regel nichts Gutes im Schilde diese einfache Erkenntnis sollte sich auch in unserer Rechtsordnung wieder spielen mit Türen.
Bestell einfach mal fest.
Demokratie brauchen wir die Meinungsfreiheit ja gar nicht mehr.
In der Diktatur ist ja klar das ist dass es Möglichkeiten zum Widerstand geben musste aber doch nicht in einer Demokratie,
was was denken Mensch.
Naja da gibt's dann guckst du einfach das ja eh database nach.
Hinter dem Team in der Demokratie brauchen wir keine freie Presse ist doch eine Demokratie selbstverständlich in 1 in einer in einer Autokratie wich ist Meinungsfreiheit und Pressefreiheit wichtig aber in einer Demokratie doch.
Genesis Auto wenn der CIA da da bist drin steht dass wir keine mehr sind das ist Verlaub.
Genau dann erlauben wir das auch wieder ne dann wird.
Ja klar wenn die dritte Diktatur da ist wird das Auto.
Da ist wird automatisch das Darknet wieder erlaubt so wir sind jetzt zu Diktatur dhadakne muss jetzt wieder sein.
Danach auch wieder Pressefreiheit.
Dass das haben jetzt lange genug verboten als wir noch eine Demokratie waren aber jetzt natürlich nicht mehr was rauchen die hat er die ganze Aservatenkammer leer geraucht oder was.
Keine Ahnung also davon bin ich auf jeden Fall nicht abhaben.
Aber ich habe so einen vorsichtiges,
Gefühl dass da noch was auf uns zukommen wird in genau dieser Richtung denn was wurde jetzt schon diskutiert,
digitaler Hausfriedensbruch ja wir haben im Prinzip in Deutschland im Bereich des hacking,
eine krasse Gesetzgebung dir sogar die quasi die Vorbereitung des Abspielens von Daten unter Strafe stellt die sich darin zeigt dass man Puls entwickelt die dazu geeignet sein könnten,
im Prinzip ist jede Form von Security Scanner was weiß ich von enmap bis,
Ruf auf concept alles was ihnen was mit was ID Sicherheit verletzen könnte oder geeignet wäre zur Vorbereitung des Ausspähens von Daten sowieso schon unter Strafe.
Muss mal für die Tools noch passend erweitern ich würde vorschlagen Microsoft Excel.
Ja genau verboten Vorbereitung des Ausspähens von.
Ach die haben da Excel auf Ihrem Computer.
Excel was der Computer bootet Vorbereitung des Ausspähens von Daten.
Sorry wir müssen Sie leider mitnehmen.
Und jetzt haben wir.
Bekennerschreiben wer noch mit Word geschrieben.
Jetzt haben wir ja wir haben es in Deutschland ohnehin schon eine relativ relativ krasse Gesetzgebung in diesem Bereich die bis zu rent bis zur Entwicklung oder dem bekloppt oder den Besitz von Software die dazu geeignet ist,
reicht.
Und jetzt geht's halt darum und und wir haben auch diesen Paragraph Ausspähen von Daten f****** ist Nordirland in the Netherlands und es ist auch not allowed in the German lands Haki ist verboten.
Und jetzt kommen die aber hin und komm mit mir zu DTH digitale Hausfriedensbruch muss auch verboten werden,
was auch immer das sein soll es gibt nämlich keine Straftatbestände die,
darüber hinausgehende was das Ausspähen von Daten oder eben diese Angriffe geht aber du du hörst Formulierungen wie digitaler Hausfriedensbruch,
unbefugter Zugriff,
ja was jetzt auch quasi in in Straftatbestände überführt werden soll weil sich da irgendwie eine Schutzlücke gedacht wird und es würde mich nicht wundern.
Wenn wir im IP Sicherheits gesetzt auch etwas finden wie z.b. die das verboten.
Darknet.
Infrastrukturen Darknet was ich vorhin oder Marktplätze die geeignet sind oder die weiße also so in Formulierung wieder EU Copyright richtigen sie letztendlich
ein Verein Verbotes des da von dem Display des reinen Betriebes von Darknet Infrastruktur nach sich ziehen ohne Probleme wenn du eine torminal Note betreibst also einen Server der,
nichts anderes macht als Daten im Darknet hin und her schicken ohne in der Lage zu sein da rein zu blicken.
Dann kannst du natürlich sehr schnell daraus Spinnen dass du hier Beihilfe zur zum zum Terror leistest,
relativ einfach sind zwei Sätze schreibst du in so ein Gesetz rein und gut ist ja.
Und ich wäre sehr vorsichtig ob wir auch nicht solche verrückten Ideen.
Im in einem IT Sicherheitsgesetz finden können.
Bitte cynster den Version 4.0.
Ich tippe auf 2.
Und dann fragt man sich aber du hast jetzt irgendwie dieses ID Sicherheitsgesetz in Deutschland was hat das alte Sicherheit gesetzt eigentlich je für uns getan na ja wir haben vor allem relativ viel Bürokratie und Pflichten
für Unternehmen bekommen die letztendlich in keiner Form wirklich auf IP Sicherheit,
angesteuert haben ja meine Kritik an maui Sicherheitsgesetz.
War ja damals im Innenausschuss als Sachverständiger was hier passiert ist,
mehr Papier allerlei Pflichten für Unternehmen allerlei Rechte für das für Strafverfolgung und BSI,
aber wenig dass ich wirklich in Schutz,
oder IP Sicherheit direkt übersetzen ist z.b. sowas wie Softwarehersteller oder so dass die sind im im aldi Sicherheitsgesetz ja gar nicht betroffen
ja du hast einfach nur Meldepflichten du musst ein Sicherheitskonzept haben oder so aber der dir den ganzen Schrott verkauft,
ist in keiner Form in Wien nz vom Aldi Sicherheitsgesetz betroffen keine Haftungsregelung keine Verpflichtung was wir immer gesagt haben,
lass doch einfach die die Software Provider haften,
verpflichtet die doch einfach Sicherheitslücken in der gewissen Zeit zu schließen belegt das doch mit Strafe Schrott an unseren Mittelstand zu verkaufen alles Möglichkeiten die richtigen Druck hätten dass ich in der Qualität,
der Software etwas ändern würde wo man sagen wo doch hier dieses Gesetz kann argumentierbar,
zum Schutz der Bürgerinnen und Bürger und der Unternehmen beitragen indem nämlich jetzt irgendetwas passiert was entweder Sicherheitslücken verhindert.
Das Ausnutzen von Sicherheitslücken erschwert oder schneller detektiert oder in irgendeiner Form einem,
upright Haltung von Möglichkeiten ist diese Sicherheitslücken entgegenzutreten,
in dieser breit Haltung von Möglichkeiten da ist das RT Sicherheitsgesetz 1.0 durchaus vertreten beim Einsatz ihr braucht ein Sicherheitskonzept ja das müsst ihr euch selber geben als Branche,
ja immer mein klassisches Beispiel der braucht die Branche kann sich gerade sagen hier die die,
der Verband der was was ihr tun Kraftwerksbetreiber hat sich jetzt folgendes Sicherheitskonzept gegeben und wenn du dich an dieses Sicherheitskonzept nicht hältst hältst oder diese diese Anforderung nicht erfüllt
dann steht das unter Strafe dann weiß natürlich auch was du da rein schreibst ne nämlich nur das was du eh schon gemacht hast das heißt einer Erhöhung der IT Sicherheit die Gefahr einer Erhöhung der IT Sicherheit ist durch das AT Sicherheitsgesetz
wirksam verhindert,
was könnten wir es wird noch diskutiert irgendwie im bevor wir jetzt irgendwann ein ID Sicherheitsgesetz und darf ja nicht vergessen das AT Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 kommt in die unter Seehofer ne das heißt Kompetenz ist da fern allerdings hat er natürlich,
nicht ganz so blöde Leute bei sich im Haus sitzen unter anderen denen.
Andreas Koenen der auch unter seinem Vorgänger schon der Staatssekretär war der auch das eine oder andere Interview gibt und der natürlich relativ klar so ein bisschen.
Sei mal für den starken Staat argumentiert will mehr Kompetenzen für das BSI
BSI soll quasi immer mehr Dienste Anbieter und so weiter sollen verpflichtet sein mit dem BSI zu kooperieren weil sie es nämlich in der Regel nicht tun weil sie sagen ihr hin hat uns an der Arbeit.
Das heißt irgendwie das BSI wird in Zweifelsfall gestärkt jetzt würde man sich natürlich wünschen Hey toll stärkt das BSI wenn ich ja sofort dabei tut uns nur bitte den Gefallen und mach das BSI unabhängig,
das ist die größte Stärke und die man einer Behörde angedeihen lassen kann.
Die Behörde oder wenn ich aufzustellen unten Clan den kleinen Auftrag zu geben der mich schützt bitte Deutschland vor Ungemach durch hacken,
und genau der Schritt wird natürlich nicht getan denn die Ideen die Andreas können seit einiger Zeit ventiliert gehen sie ein bisschen in die Richtung na ja wenn jetzt hier.
Na das BSI Kenntnis von Schwachstellen hat dann muss natürlich auch überlegt werden ob wir diese Schwachstellen nicht vielleicht im Rahmen so eines war abilities equities Prozess vielleicht auch selber nutzen,
also die Hoheit die mit den Sicherheitslücken,
Folgeverfahren wird ob wir die jetzt den Hersteller melden oder ob wir sagen 8 Uhr die für die Sicherheitslücke hat aber was weiß ich dass das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz oder der der bmt auch,
Verwendung na das was in den USA passiert ist eine Idee der jetzt das BMI seit jeher nicht abgelehnt abgeneigt gegenüber Städte.
Insofern bin ich gespannt was da wirklich am Ende bei rauskommt als in welche Gütesiegel,
wie das mit den Gütesiegeln verlaufen ist haben wir ja hier im Logbuch Netzpolitik auch über die Jahre diskutiert die es gebraucht hat bis die technische Richtlinie Router,
vom BSI veröffentlicht wurde und auch da sehe ich also wen ich einfach mal,
sinnvolle Nutzung auch der Möglichkeiten diesen Staat hätte ne und,
wahrscheinlich werden sie irgendwie Computer Straftaten und noch so ein bisschen stärker unter Strafe stellen sie werden in irgendeiner Form diese,
digital Hausfriedensbruch unbefugte Nutzung dass das sehe ich kommen und ich glaube auch dass sie irgendetwas tun werden gegen Darknet genauso wie es da gefordert wird ja also dir gerne vor mir was weiß ich.
Wer Infrastrukturen betreibt die sich für kriminelle Koordination eignen.
Der Witz steht unter Strafe fertig.
Und dann hättest du bist du ruckzuck irgendwo bei Darknet Verbot oder sogar verschlüsselte Messenger Verbot sowieso,
Quellen-TKÜ haben wir ja eh schon da können wir von ausgehen dass das natürlich dann auch noch mal ausgeweitet wird,
im im Namen der Sicherheit muss die IT Sicherheit der Bürgerinnen und Bürger natürlich weiter geschwächt werden.
Und deswegen hier noch mal mein mein Wunsch dieses Thema im Logbuch Netzpolitik ausführlich,
begleiten und meine Bitte an die Parteien ich stehe auch bei,
Heidi Sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 und 3.0 und 3.1 Workgroups und 4.0 gerne wieder als
Sachverständiger Bereich denn mir wäre es wichtig dass hier an diesem katastrophalen Zustand der Aldi Sicherheit in Deutschland und weltweit,
mal etwas getan wird und natürlich hat der Staat der Möglichkeiten.
Ja natürlich meine hat ja auch gemerkt dass ein totales Imageproblem hat mit diesem ganzen Maßnahmen und tut ja auch was dagegen.
Trojaner wenn es einfach umbenannt.
Staatstrojaner heißt nicht mehr Staatstrojaner ne.
Nee weil das ist ja negative Konnotation ist dass sie ihn dann doch aufgefallen.
Wie heißen die jetzt freedom Preis oder.
Software zur Durchführung von Maßnahmen der informationstechnischen Überwachung und geht doch locker von der Zoo.
Freedom Software.
Software des Guten ich würde hier Software des Guten nennen Software des Guten finde ich einen wunderschönen wunderschönes Beispiel.
Immerhin beruhigendes aber dass diese Institute auch von kompetenten Personal geleitet werden wir z.b. in Japan.
Ja in Japan haben wir ja den den cyberchef der den im Computer bedient hat.
Wolfenbüttel geradeaus.
Aber der ist jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit im Amt und jetzt jetzt was Neues überlegt und hat gesagt ja wir werden jetzt.
Vernetzte Geräte groß in großer Breite angreifen um die Bevölkerung auf zu schrecken,
also wenn euch schon nicht dass wenn euch das Darknet nicht hacked dann regt euch der Staat,
wie werden staatliche Hacker werden ab dem 20 Februar landesweit mehr als 200 Millionen vernetzte Geräte von Firmen und Bürgern angreifen computer und Smartphones nehmen wir aus aber dieses IOT.
Mama platt.
Ist aber alles ganz geile Idee.
Die Idee ist gar nicht so schlecht wie ihr Angriff ist jetzt Iwona deviantman 134 versuchen und so weiter ne.
Können Sie schon weit kommen.
Ja mal schauen wie weit sie damit wirklich kommen.
Ja aber,
proaktiv Sicherheit Abfahrt Essen einfach auf so minimal Druck schon mal erzeugt also selbst wenn wir wir wir wir prüfen einfach mal ob ihr die Passwörter die diese blöden Geräte bei der Auslieferung gehabt haben ob er die einfach schon mal zurückgesetzt habe.
Es ist das ist tatsächlich also das ist wirklich mal eine rechtliche Grauzone die in verschiedenen Ländern immer wieder seine Probleme aufwirft,
was wäre jetzt z.b. wenn es Schwachstellen gäbe nehmen wir diesen telekom-router Ausfall ja wenn nun.
Der Staat ermächtigt wäre in diesem Fall.
Traffic der auf diese Geräte zugeht zu blockieren oder sogar verwundbare Geräte zu hacken und zu patchen also du kannst hacken heißt ja erstmal in erster Instanz nur in irgendeiner Form,
Geräte oder Teile des Gerätes unter deine Kontrolle bringen unter bestimmten Umständen,
bist du dadurch in der Lage auch die Sicherheitslücken zu entfernen gab es auch in der Vergangenheit schon erstens wurden,
gabs diesen Breaker bot der Geräte kaputt gemacht hat und dadurch die Leute zu zwingen
die Firmware neu einzuspielen und das Gerät damit zu updaten bzw das Gerät kaputt gemacht hat so dass es nicht mehr die ganze Zeit die du hast gemacht hatte,
die Übernahme von command-and-control Servern
die von bestimmten Botnetzen genutzt wurden oder eben auch jetzt hier telekom-router die Idee was weiß ich Angriff läuft Schachtel ist bekannt Leute haben nicht gepatcht BSI geht hin
texi Geräte und und Pezi wer eine Idee die,
vielleicht uns im Rahmen des AT Sicherheitsgesetz ist auch noch mal als als Diskussion interessiert.
So jetzt aber wirklich bei den Kurzmeldungen angelangt im nur das nur als Warnung.
Ja ich bin gewarnt.
Der digitalpakt Schule scheint in Zweifelsfall stattfinden zu können wir letzte Woche schon gesagt und jetzt jetzt also auch so wirklich stinkt ganz ganz kurz davor dass der digitalpakt Schule jetzt durchkommt,
also die Digitalisierung.
Wird zeitnah stattfinden die Digitalisierung der Kinder wird Nichtleiter weiter verzögert,
wir drücken hier weiterhin die Daumen denk doch bitte mal an die Kinder.
Freecom Hyper die Kinder genau.
Und ebenfalls erwähnt die EU wird es jetzt in die Wege leiten.
Und das Personalausweise künftig Fingerabdruck enthalten müssen.
Jetzt ist das nicht so lange her dass ich meinen neuen Personalausweis bekommen habe ich glaube dass ich hatte ich da die Wahrheit ich habe es auf jeden Fall nicht gemacht ich weiß nur noch nicht ich weiß tatsächlich was ich.
Zugeben ich weiß nicht genau ob ich das ob ich die Wahl gehabt hätte meine Fingerabdrücke dort abzugeben beim beim Pass musste ich.
Personalausweis weiß ich nicht müsste ich eigentlich wissen.
Und jetzt ist halt so soll auf jeden Fall dann mit der neuen Ehe die Regelungen der durch die EU soll das daneben vereinheitlicht werden
zwei Fingerabdrücke müssen gespeichert werden auf dem Personalausweis Personalausweis muss maschinenlesbar sein im Kreditkartenformat aufgegeben werden Foto enthalten,
Foto ja auch geometrisch und in digitaler Form übermittelt.
Und wir haben in Deutschland ja eh schon das war die letzt das letzte die letzte EEG Gesetz Novelle die den zentralen Zugriff auf die biometrischen Daten die wir da abgelegt.
Fertig mit Kurzmeldung.
14 Stunden so ein Staat sind start es gibt für ein Lied von Hans Söllner erkennst du dass er wahnsinnig habe ich noch nie Hey Staat soll ganz schönes Lied.
Sind entweder von jetzt sag ich dir mal was ich alles für dich mache und dann erzählst du mir mal,
was du für mich warst Fingerabdruck haben Steuern bezahlen darf keine YouTube Videos mehr machen der ist ein bisschen älter dieses lied aber in solchen Situationen,
fühle ich mich daran erinnern nicht nur deshalb nicht nur weil ich gerade dabei bin meine Steuererklärung fertig zu machen höre ich dieses lied gerade,
vermehrt in in meinem in meinem Raum kopierten mp3.
Zusagen für das nächste Segment aber dann erstmal an andere.
Am 6. April 2019 findet an der Hochschule Augsburg der Augsburger LinuxTag statt,
es geht natürlich in work in work Dragon und Forscher,
um Linux und Open-Source-Software aber natürlich auch um die digitale Gesellschaft kreative Anwendung von Technik Wissenschaft und Bildung das ganze wird organisiert von der Linux User Group,
Augsburg und es gibt einen CFP Dennis wird noch weiter gesucht nach worktrain und for shops und den Link zum call for papers findet ihr bei uns
Shownotes.
Linux User Group Augsburg
und haben schon erwähnt Demo Demo Demo gegen Artikel 13 und alles was da dran hängt in Berlin am 2. März statt vor dem Axel Springer Hochhaus dann geht's weiter über die Friedrichstraße zum Justizministerium und dann weiter die Friedrichstraße entlang
und unter den Linden zur Vertretung der EU-Kommission am Brandenburger Tor dort darf ein bisschen gewinkt werden los geht's um 13 Uhr,
angemeldet ist die Demo bis 16 Uhr dreißig Uhr.
Nimmt euch also nichts vor vielleicht gibt's ja auch Musik.
Könnte sein.
Und jetzt schon im Kalender markieren natürlich auch den 23.03 wo Europameister wird Europa sich erheben.
Und ihr wisst das war sehr erfolgreich reizt dann.
Dann sind wir schon beim Dank an gelangten.
Ja mindestens.
Dann würde ich gerne danken einer unbekannten Person Michael Michael Christian Sören Benjamin Max Fabian Franziska Thomas und tim.
Sohn.
So einfach kannst du da was zu sagen.
Ja dass das lustigerweise jetzt unsere erste Logbuch Netzpolitik Sendung dieses Jahres war wo wir in Angesicht zu Angesicht und gegenübersitzen hat bestimmt ja keiner gemerkt.
Izle7 weißt du.
Opern seit Januar alles alles remote gemacht.
Boah.
Keiner hat es gemerkt.
Keiner hat gemerkt Internet geil ne Internet ist geil das man darf das eigentlich nicht vergessen und deswegen lohnt sich das auch immer wieder.
Dafür irgendwie zu kämpfen wenn auch dann demnächst im Darknet Logbuch Darknet.
Weil ich weiß ja nicht wie lange wir das hier noch hochgeladen bekommen ne bevor uns das hier die ARD und was weiß ich wem die ganze Musik hier gehört wieder wegnimmt.
Ja das ist wirklich doof muss er sein der Gedanke
dass ich jetzt so einer Generation gehöre die ganze Internet einmal hat schon richtig ordentlich durchatmen können und später soll es dann nicht mehr so sein und zwar für immer
sich ist nicht so geil also gibt's schon einiges was man zu kritisieren hat an der Struktur des Netzes und nicht alles ist schön aber grundsätzlich sind wieder mit einem gut gefahren.
Was ich ganz was ich ganz spannend finde es wär nur wenn du dir so vorstellst wenn jetzt ältere Menschen dir erzählen von Innovationen die gekommen sind nein wieso warst du sowas dann gab es Farbfotografie,
so oder du konntest dann wurde die Polaroid Sofortbildkamera erfunden das hat die Welt veränderte man konnte seine Bilder sofort sehen oder dann kam die Gurtpflicht,
also Geschichten kriegt er erzählt von Leuten die,
paar Jahre älter sind nur und ich sehe mich schon irgendwann so in 30 Jahren,
auf dem auf dem 64 Chaos Communication Congress somit mit langen langen Haaren und Rauschebart irgendwie,
als Hologramm,
auf der virtuellen Vereinigung dann erzählen so war das damals das war ein Computer der hatte 105-tasten ja das war ein Tastatur da konnte man Sätze,
rein das musst du mal lernen das war anfangs sehr schwierig aber mit über die Monate hat man dann gelernt da was einzutippen,
und dann haben wir dann haben wir.
Ihre eigenen Reihen tuscheln sie mit den Fingern.
Sind fega und
und dann hatten wir ihr wieder kein Mobilfunk auf einmal war mal überall erreichbar früher vorher musst du man sich wenn man sich verabredet hat musste man das an der Weltzeituhr machen ja
und und dann hatten wir und dann gab's ein Netz dann gab's dieses Internet Sekunden wir für einen kurzen Moment konnte man da machen was was man will das hieß Internet
bevor das also bevor das irgendwann Google oder Facebook alles gekauft hatte,
das sieht Netzwerk und dann stehst du da und erzählst alle diese Geschichten und die sitzt der neben seinen Wahnsinn Wahnsinn damit seid ihr so habt ihr gelebt,
die geliebt.
Wie die Tiere.
Ja da ist sie wieder konnte jeder ins Internet hochladen was er wollte ja bis hingegangen etwas geschrieben,
javi gab es gab es da eine egal kannst da keine.
Warte.
Gab es da keinen keinen automatischen Filter hat da nicht die hat ja nicht die künstliche Intelligenz zwischen Parodie und original unterschieden kann doch nicht sein.
Oh Gott.
Und das ist,
dieses kemading ne die künstliche Intelligenz unterscheidet zwischen Parodie und original ja tut sie tut sie ziemlich genau weil das weil ihr in die recht.
Rechteinhaber seit die sagen das gehört uns jetzt ja und alles was was was irgendwo Ähnlichkeit damit hat wird gelöscht die hier diese diese YouTube-Videos sie am laufenden Band gelöscht werden was muss doch dieses schöne Dinger wo
war das denn diese feministische Gruppierung Erwin geiles Video gemacht hatte und dann hatte RTL2
Ausschnitte darf oder RTL Ausschnitte davon offenbar sich über den Äther gejagt Ihre Sendung hochgeladen,
und dann als nächstes tja automatische Filter hat dann denen Ihr Video gelöscht weil sie sagt aber er hat mir davon RTL geklaut haben die 22 Wochen vorher hochgeladen und weil Ihr Video aber RTL war ja offenbar das Original so einfach wird sehr sittkus er Dirigent
da geht auch heute schon und ungefähr auf dem Niveau bewegt euch auch mit eurer Argumentation.
Na bei RTL war das dann legitimiert Parodie.
RTL ist echt illegitime Parodie.
Und Ausbeute.
Offene.
Kinder wir sind weiter für mich habe ich mir wie viele wie viele Jahre servier.de Widerstand auf der Gehalt jetzt muss Generation YouTube kommen und übernehmen.
Ja nicht nur Generation YouTube also immer in all dem Ärger den wir hier regelmäßig,
zum Ausdruck bringen sehe ich ja auch jetzt schon erste Ansätze der Revolution so diese erstmal genau die Friday Demonstration gegen Klimawandel,
wurde die Schüler jetzt quasi sagen ich gehe mal nicht zur Schule ich mache jetzt hier mal Streik.
Friday for climate.
Weil vertan hast du ja ich weiß ich ganz genau Friday night of future und was war das,
ja bitte mehr davon ja also das,
caydes Verstecke also das muss jetzt einfach mal stattfinde ich wette auch ein bisschen unruhig jetzt also,
wenn irgendwie euch für Jungen haltet also oder wenn er uns als alt empfindet dann seid ihr diejenigen die jetzt mal mehr tun müssen.
Und zwar so richtig also ich erwarte brennende Mülltonnen und zwar hier nicht so silicon mäßig sein halt mit Style.
Sika Lagerfeld der übrigens die gelbe Weste salonfähig gemacht hat um noch einen weiteren deutschen.
Er hat die gelbe Weste sagen.
Karl Lagerfeld hat die gelbe Weste salonfähig.
Wodurch Hattersheim Models umgehängt oder was.
Nee der hat irgendwie gesagt.
Sie ist gelb sie ist hässlich sie passt zu nichts aber sie könnte Dein Leben.
Gesagt ok aber da dass ich nicht auf die Demos bezogen verstehe das ohne Werbung.
Hat er geworben für die gelbe Weste bei Otto.
Ja weiß ich also wenn euch Demonstration nicht cool genug sind dann könnt ihr euch ja bei Karl Lagerfeld vielleicht die Sonnenbrille abgucken irgendwie dann haben wir die Sonnenbrillen Revolution ja.
Der Mutter sind schon ganz cool.
Nehme ich alles ja ist mir egal denkt euch war einfach was aus aber tut bitte mal was also.
Wetter in 80er Jahren auch hinter so und jetzt sollen wir Tschüss bis nächste Woche.
Würde ich sagen ja.
Bunte kinderfrisuren besang Tschüss bis bald.